[Musique]
Rwanda à la poursuite des génocidaires
documentairirees exclusif réalisés par
Thomas Ribi et Stéphane Joubert en
1994 vous venez de le voir d'froosagtier
a vu sa famille en grande partie
assassiné durant le génocide au Rwanda
depuis avec son mari Alain elle n'a eu
de 16 d'enquêter sur ceux qui ont
participé à ces crimes et qui se sont
réfugiés dans notre pays pour qu'ils y
soient jugés mais où en est-on au juge
concernant la traque mise en œuvre pour
débusquer et juger les génocidaires
rwandais nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités après ce
film d'afroagotier est présente avec
nous sur ce plateau de débadog bienvenue
à vous avec votre mari Alain vous avez
donc fondé en 2001 le collectif des
parties civiles pour le Rwanda qui s'est
donc fixé pour objectif on l'a très bien
vu bien sûr dans ce film de traduire
devant les juridictions françaises les
personnes soupçonnées d'avoir participé
au gnocide des tout de s par les outou
c'était entre avril et juillet
1994 et qui ont trouvé refuge en France
en précisant aussi que le film que nous
venons de voir est également accompagné
d'une bande dessinée du même titre
d'ailleurs que le film Rwanda à la
poursuite des génocidaires co-écrit par
Thomas Ribi et le dessinateur Damien
Roudeau vous savez j'ai lu qu'on vous
comparaît ni plus ni moins au couple
carsfeld avec vous et votre mari Alain
le couple carsfeld célèbre chasseur de
nazi euh ça vous inspire quoi non
écoutez je pense que c'est pas nous qui
nous sommes nommés ou comparés je pense
que c'est on compare le travail qui est
fait traquer un Azis rwandais ou un Azis
allemand pour moi il n'y a pas de
différence éric kemerau est également
avec nous bienvenue merci de votre
invitation vous êtes ancien colonel
ancien chef de l'Office central de lutte
contre les crimes contre l'hum humanité
les génocides et les crimes de guerre
qui a été créé en 2013 et vous êtes
aussi l'auteur de ce livre La Traque est
mon métier publié aux édition plomb
c'est vous et votre équipe qui avait
notamment débusqué Félicien katouba qui
était financier présumé du génocide des
touts on étaé question d'ailleurs à un
moment dans ce documentaire et puis
enfin Laurent Larcher est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes journaliste au
quotidien Lacroix essayiste on vous doit
Rwanda il parle témoignage pour
l'histoire ouvrage publié au Seuil et
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule
souviens-toi mémoire à l'usage des
générations futures un livre que vous
avez que écrit avec Jean Varet et qui
est disponible aux éditions Les Arènes
un point important il sera un tout petit
peu long mais je crois qu'il est
nécessaire pour bien comprendre dans
quoi s'inscrit le film que nous venons
de voir et l'échange que nous allons
avoir ensemble entre 2005 et 2012
environ 2 millions de personnes ont été
jugées au Rwanda pour ce génocide commis
en
1994 par les utou sur les TSI les
autorités rwandaises ont pour cela
relancé les garakas qui s'inspiraient
des anciennes assemblées dans lesquelles
les sages des villages réglaient les
conflits et les contentieux cela
représentait quelques 12100 tribunaux
populaires et puis et puis parallèlement
pour juger les principaux responsables
cette fois de ce génocide le conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU a créé en novembre
1994 le Tribunal international pour le
Rwanda basé en Tanzanie qui fermera
officiellement le 31 décembre 2015 il
inculpera officiellement 93 personnes en
condamnera 61 à la prison à vie puis le
relais sera pris par le mécanisme pour
les tribunaux pénaux internationaux
toujours de
l'Organisation des Nations unies afin
que les derniers fugitif soit arrêté
transféré et jugé et c'est bien sûr là
que commence à intervenir bien
évidemment votre collectif malgré tout
je dis bien malgré tout est-ce que vous
considérez que la justice est passée
concernant les principaux génocidaires
rwandais
euh quelques ans oui quelques ans ils
ont été jugés au Tribunal international
pour Rwanda donc le TPIR en Tanzanie
d'autres ont été jugés ailleurs en
Belgique par exemple la Belgique a jugé
en France on a six personnes
aujourd'hui qui ont été jugées et dont
trois définitivement et bien évidemment
le bilan est maigre mais la justice est
en marche elle est arrivée très tard et
vous dites c'est plutôt votre Marie qui
le dit dans ce dans ce film il resterait
en France aujourd'hui une centaine
de personnes qui auraient participé à à
ce génocide en
94 c'est un chiffre que vous comment
vous pouvez évaluer les choses vous avez
des sources pour évaluer ces chiffres
oui on a des sources on a oui on a des
sources moi je dirais même plus mais bon
une centaine c'est déjà pas mal votre
office donc a été chargé de de
traquer ces génocidaires mais pas
seulement cela hein parce que évidemment
le génocide Rwanda n'était que qu'une
partie de de votre travail au sein de
cet office néanmoins euh des anciens
génocidaires Randa il en existe combien
dans le monde aujourd'hui et où sont-ils
est-ce qu'on a seulement des données sur
ce sujet alors lorsque j'étais au Rwanda
pour en avoir parlé au procureur chargé
de ce type d'investigation il me disait
enfin il me parlait du chiffre de 1000 à
peu près ouais réparti autour de la
planète 300 euh 600 autour du du Rwanda
à peu près et et et 300 et 400 répartis
autour de la planète donc 600 d'entre
eux seraient encore au moin de là non
ils sont dans les des pays limitrophes
en fait en
RDC partout quoiouais d'accord pour ce
qui est de l'Europe la Belgique l'ancien
pays colonisateur du du Rwanda et la
France pas seulement les chiffres citer
cette centaine de de personnes qui se
tererit dans sur notre territoire ça
vous paraît euh plausible c'est
également le chiffre dont vous disposiez
au sein de votre office alors au sein de
l'office nous on travaille sur les
enquêtes qui ont été on va dire que que
que le parquet national antiterroriste
en l'occurrence le le pôle crime contre
l'humanité nous demande de de digentter
donc à partir de là nous on avait à peu
près avant que je quitte l'Office
environ une trentaine de dossiers je
vous repose la même question est-ce qu'à
votre avis contenu des enquêtes des
reportages que vous avez pu effectuer
euh la justice est passée pour
l'essentiel concernant cette ce génocide
au Rwanda non non sûr que non bien sûr
que non d'abord comment comment
voulez-vous que la justice puisse
répondre et réparer un génocide c'est
impossible on est devant un événement
monstre dont qui est un abîme qui est à
mon sens sans fond et aucune justice ne
peut réparer ça et sera à la hauteur de
cet événement car cet événement dépasse
toute dimensions premièrement ensuite
quand au génocidaires il faut pas
confondre les responsables et ceux qu'
ont commis le génocide les petites mains
et là ils sont beaucoup plus que 600
puisquon estime environ 80 % de la
population avoir participé directement
au génocide
% ce sont des millions de personnes qui
sont concernées du côté des bourreaux et
là aussi avec cette éternelle question
peut-être de se demander où où doit
commencer où doit finir une épuration
pour reprendre un terme qu'on a utilisé
après guerre dans d'utres pays par
exemple mais là il s'agit pas d'une
épuration il s'agit de de vraiment de
traquer des gens qui ont commis
l'irréparable c'est pas simplement des
gens qui ont collaboré mais des gens qui
ont participé activement à des crimes et
là encore une fois c'est l'une des
singularités de ce génocide des toutci
c'est que nous avons sans doute pour la
première fois dans l'histoire des
génocides l'oire d' l'humanité une
population qui a été mobilisée dans son
entièreté pour l'extermination d'une
partie de sa population c'est ça qui est
tout à fait fou donc là comment
voulez-vous qu'on qu'on rendre justice 1
et deux comment voulez-vous qu'on juge
tout le monde c'est déjà impossible
quant à ceux qui sont en France il y a
les responsables mais il y a aussi
encore une fois tous ceux qui ne qui
n'étaient pas des figures importantes
dans la dans la hiérarchie dans
l'administration dans l'état dans
l'armée mais qui ont profité ou qui ont
participé ou ou qui ont adhéré à cette
idéologie et là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de de retrouver les gens qui
adhèrent ou qui ont adhéré à cette
idéologie et moi pour enquêter beaucoup
sur cette question je constate
que j'ai rencontré des gens d'origine
randaise qui adhère bien sûr encore
aujourd'ui vous allez au Congo par
exemple vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
ont qui qui ont adhéré à cette idéologie
et qui n'ont qui sont toujours dans
cette logique qu'un touts c'est bien
quand c'est mort quoi et que le travail
n'a pas été terminé et qu'il faudrait
quand même le terminer et ça c'est pas
des centaines c'est moi je pense que
c'est plus que des milliers c'est des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont encore infectés par cette idéologie
parce que c'est une idéologie qui dès
lors que vous êtes dedans il est très
très difficile comme pour le nazisme
d'en sortir c'est quasiment impossible
et en plus vous risquez de la donner en
héritage à vos enfants et là où nous
sommes à la deè Gén première enfin 2è
génération des génocides et on le sait
les enfants des
génocidaires épousent
la vision de parents et là on est devant
donc des chiffres qui sont
juste difficil à saisir on va voir un
extrait du documentaire vous étiez sur
place et vous étiez à la quête bien
entendu de témoignage concernant celui
qui être jugé en France
[Musique]
B
[Applaudissements]
alors cet extrait il est là pour
concrétiser ce qui votre travail avec ce
collectif il s'agit de rassembler des
témoignages de retrouver des témoins et
puis le cas échéant de faire venir ses
témoins ensuite à un procès qui aura
lieu en France comme ça sera le cas pour
pour biguma c'est extrêmement difficile
en réalité de faire ce travail retrouver
des témoins recueillir des témoignages
euh expliquez-nous la difficulté du
travail que vous avez à réaliser à ce
stade
euh c'est un travail j'allais dire
ingrat c'est un travail où on ne peut
pas se reposer une fois qu'on est sur
une piste de tueur ou sur une enquête il
faut continuellement avancer il faut
chercher des témoins il faut aller sur
place il faut revenir il faut retourner
euh voir d'autres les entendre ceux qui
ont
euh témoigner parfois au téléphone ce
qui nous ont alerté ce que N on n'a pas
vu la fois d'avant c'est réellement un
travail de longue haleine et euh oui et
nous sommes bientôt 30 ans après les
fait j'imagine que ça ne fait que
complexifier votre action
bien naturellement je pense que bientôt
on ne pourra plus du tout euh faire des
procès puisque les témoins disparaissent
euh parce que
euh oui tout simplement ne puisque la
disparition des témoins puisque tout ne
repose que sur le
témoignage s'agissant de nos procès donc
il y a pas d'écrit ou très très très peu
et en cela malheureusement on sera
obligé oui d'arrêter parce qu' depuis la
création de votre collectif à combien de
reprises êtes-vous allé au Rwanda pour
recueillir ces témoignag convaincre ces
témoins de venir ensuite aller témoigner
leur de procès en France et bien des des
des procès il n'y en a pas eu beaucoup
pas énormément malheureusement il y en a
eu six jusquà là dont trois
condamnations définitives et à chaque
fois vous êtes aller sur place ben
c'est-à-dire que un dossier parfois
c'est au moins 10 voyages he au moins 10
voyages si ce n'est pas plus mais ce
qu'on fait c'est on combine parfois deux
trois quand on a un dossier qui est très
avancé on travaille sur le suivant sur
l'autre mais généralement on se
concentre maintenant qu'il y a des
procès on se concentre sur le procès à
venir aujourd'hui on en a un en novembre
donc on est on a le focus sur celui-là
mais aussi on a pense à celui qui va
arriver l'année prochaine donc mais non
c'est un travail assez rude c'est pas
c'est pas évident sur cette traque euh
peut-être sur notre territoire français
puisque c'est évidemment ce qui
intéresse sans doute le plus ceux qui
nous regardent aujourd'hui où se
cache-t-il comment se cache-t-il comment
est-ce qu'on les débusque euh est-ce
sont un peu monsieur tout le monde
aujourd'hui quand est-ce qu'il pour la
plupart sont-ils arrivés en France j'ai
vu que au début des années 2000 on a vu
on aurait vu vu se réfugier en France un
certain nombre d'entre eux qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire concernant en fait
la plupart d'entre eux en doosse le le
camouflage du citoyen modèle
c'est-à-dire que leur objectif est de
surtout pas faire de vague de rester en
dessous de sous le radar et donc c'est
vrai que le travail du CPCR pour nous
est indispensable puisque eux ils font
ce travail de détection à la fois au
Rwanda mais bien sûr en France et que
nous notre base en fait de de compétence
s'inscrit à partir du moment où l'indivu
est en France une fois qu'on a commencé
donc cette trque ça a été le cas pour
pour biguma donc sur la base de tous les
éléments les témoignages qui sont
victimes aussi auteurs qui sont
recueillis par le CPCR nous on va tout
reprendre c'estàd que notre objectif est
de transformer l'essai transformer
l'essai de de tout ce travail qui est
fait par par les ONG parce que c'est
vrai pour le Rwanda c'est vrai pour le
Liberia c'est vrai pour la syrieon et
donc une fois qu'on a déterminé le
positionnement de l'individu en France
on va travailler sur une enquête
judiciaire traditionnelle c'est-à-dire
qu'on va en gros mettre en œuvre trois
travailler dans trois environnements un
environnement physique un environnement
digital et un environnement financier
donc sur l'environnement physique bah là
on utilise toutes les techniques
d'enquête traditionnelles qu' qu'on a
pour que la loi nous donne en matière de
lutte antiterroriste par exemple donc ça
veut dire des écoutes téléphoniques des
surveillances des filatures des
sonorisations enfin tout ce dont on a
besoin et ensuite bien sûr on va
confronter si tout cette tous ces
élémentsl avec l'environnement digital
actuel qui est très important puisque
tout le monde utilise des téléphones
tout le monde utilise internet donc on
ben on comment dire on balaye tout ça et
enfin l'environnement financier
d'ailleurs c'est grâce à l'environnement
financier qu'on a pu détecter bigoma qui
s'était caché au Cameroun parce que pour
le coup on fait nous aussi des
allers-retours entre la France et le
Rwanda et quand on part au Rwanda bien
sûr on commence à entendre des témoins
des victimes et il se peut que il y ait
une fuite dans nos dossiers et voilà
c'est ce qui s'est passé en gros il a
quitté la France donc sur le travail de
de surveillance de sa famille on a pu
très rapidement s'apercevoir qu'il y
avait des Western Union des flux
financiers qui partait vers le Cameroun
et comme on est on s'inscrit dans une
logique de coopération internationale
étroite avec Europol Eurojust et puis
les différentes structures de l'ONU que
vous avez cité parce que le terrain de
chasse est international il est
international et que sans coopération
déjà simple comme ça c'est très
compliqué et sans coopération ce serait
impossible et là donc sur la base de de
ces éléments là on a pu savoir quels
étaient les flux financiers et savoir
qu'effectivement il était positionné au
Cameroun donc après derrière il nous
suffit de placer des alertes et des
sonnettes sur sa famille et puis quand
on s'est aperçu que il y avait un
mouvement qui était possible par sa
femme en l'occurrence puis qu'il allait
prendre l'avion il suffisait de mettre
un comité d'accueil en lien avec la
coopération internationale et les
mandats d'arrêt internationaux qui avent
été livré à son égard et donc à partir
de là il a été arrêté sur place à
l'aéroport quand il venait chercher sa
femme et ramené chez nous en France
alors après il est resté un long moment
quand même au Cameroun en en détention
provisoire et ensuite effectivement il a
été extradé en
France et pour être jugé Laurent Larcher
est-ce qu'il y a des filières qui ont
permis à ces génocid rwandais de
s'exfiltrer en France alors c'est c'est
très difficile d'enquêter sur ce sur
cette question là c'est vraiment il y a
un tel flou un tel vous venez d'entendre
enfin moi je savais pas il y avait même
des
fuites au sein même de ceux qui sont
chargés d'enquêter sur ces génocidaires
donc vous imaginez un peu le je dirais
le le le brouillard qui qui entoure tout
ça alors ensuite on peut oui imaginer
qu'il y a évidemment des filières ouais
quelles sont-elles ces filières qu'on
qu'on peut imaginer alors enfin on peut
imaginer qu'il y a des filières déjà de
de relation
amicales des alors pour prendre le cas
de la France des gens qui ont travaillé
au Ronda ou qui ont travaillé sur le
dossier rondais qui ont établi des
relations personnelles avec les uns et
les autres et qui se sentent comme une
forme de loyauté vis-à-vis des uns et
des autres donc ils lu vont filer des
coups de mains euh on parle aussi d'une
filière catholique existe-t-elle alors
et pourquoi
euh il est aussi évident là c'est un
autre aspect du dossier euh qu'il y a
aussi des catholiques dans parmi les
génocidaires et euh et que l'Église
catholique au Randa mais aussi dans sa
relation avec les autres églises et
notamment avec l'église française il y a
là des choses assez oui il y a eu des
des
contacts moi je pense que je sais pas si
ce sont des filiats mais du moins des
des mouvements comme le Secours
Catholique peut-être ou le CCFD euh
alors je dis pas que c'est une ce sont
des filières instituées parce que c'est
une accusation très grave mais il y a
sans doute eu des des billets des
facilités encore une fois pour des
questions de loyauté aussi des gens qui
ne compr comprenait pas ce qui s'était
passé ou qui avait qui partageait la
vision du du du du enfin du comment dire
de l'époque d'abarimana qui sentait que
les outou étaient plutôt les victimes et
touts les coupables hein c'est un peu
malheureusement cette inversion qu'il y
a dans la tête de beaucoup qui qui avait
dans la tête des gens de l'époque et qui
restent et qui demeure encore je le
crains dans la tête d'un certain nombre
de nos contemporains euh et donc il y a
des facilités ça c'est certain
euh on sait qu'il y a eu des évêques
français qui ont été au rendant en 94 du
moins à Goma qui ont été frappés par les
séminaristes qu'ils ont rencontrés ou
tout ou tout ou des prêtres ou tout qui
l'uront diffuser une vision totalement
infondée du génocide en inversant les
choses encore une fois face à ces ce
qu'ils ont vu ils ont été bouleversés et
comme par hasard on a retrouvé des
prêtres dont le passé prêtres randais
dont le passé était quand même très très
comment dire ambigu pour ne pas dire fou
se retrouverver prête dans des diocèses
de ces de ces évêces là et là c'est un
vrai problème c'est un problème d'autant
plus que il me semble que l'Église
catholique n'a pas l'église française
n'a jamais enquêter sur ces questions là
on va écouter un instant votre mari
Alain avec un nouvel extrait du film
depuis plus de 20 ans nous avons déposé
plus d'une trentaine de plaintes et
jusqu'à maintenant malheureusement seul
C personnes ont été jugé et
condamné
[Musique]
la France c'est pratiquement le seul
pays aujourd'hui qui refuse toujours
d'extrader ces personnesl vers le Rwanda
où ils auraient déjà été jugés alors les
questions des lenteurs évidemment de de
de notre justice he sur ces dossiers je
crois que pour espérer voir
juger un ancien génocidaire faut faut 10
ans et puis c'est un coup aussi c'est
environ un million d'euros hein c'est ça
il dis donc qu'il faut compter 5 ans
appel 2 ans et cassation 2 ou 3 ans donc
ça fait 10 et votre mari dit dans dans
cet extrait la France est pratiquement
le seul pays aujourd'hui qui refuse
toujours d'extrader ces personnes vers
le Rwanda ce qui aurait permis déjà de
les juger où est le problème là pourquoi
la France refuse
d'extrader ses ex génocidaires wand moi
je pense c'est une question de droit il
faudrait peut-être poser cette question
à la Cour de cassation qui refuse qu'il
y a des arrêts qui refusent de les
extrader au départ on nous disait que il
y avait la peine de mort au Rwanda la
peine de mort n'existe pas on disait que
le tpier n'extrade pas au Rwanda le
tpier a extradé au Rwanda et maintenant
la dernier des derniers c'est que la loi
organique
euh post génocide enfin a été élaboré
après le génocide donc en fait c'est
comme si la France n'aurait pas pu par
exemple juger Papon mais on ne va quand
même pas produire des lois avant même
que le crime ne soit commis donc c'est
complètement insensis je crois que c'est
à la Cour de cassation de à leur
magistrats de répondre à cette question
que nous on ne comprend absolument pas
c'est vrai que c'est difficile à
comprendre he puisque des procès de
suspect du génocide randais ont eu lieu
en Belgique en Suisse en Allemagne au
Canada en Finlande en Norvège en Suède
aux Pays-Bas et eux ces pays
parallèlement
extradit certains génocidaires nous en
France on le fait pas vous avez une
réponse à cette question bah déjà oui da
frosa a donné quelques éléments il y a
ces problématiques de droit bon
récemment il y a un arrêt de la Cour de
cassation qui a fait évoluer une
problématique un peu similaire euh avec
les
Syriens les relations aussi
diplomatiques sont comment dire de plus
en plus euh comment dire flu Ave paiser
avec le Rwanda donc on peut peut-être
estimer que dans les années qui viennent
les choses évoluent et ça ferait
réellement accélérer les procédures pour
juger ses génocida randais comme le dit
alin gtier dans cet extrait votre mari
oui B inévitablement parce que en fait
quand VO on l'a dit au départ nous on
travaille sur 150 dossiers qui
concernent la planète entière entre le
Sri Lanka bon bref ça veut dire que à un
moment donné on a quand même pas des
enquêteurs qui sont en permanence dédiés
en tout le temps pour le pour le donc
forcément souffle ça suppose quand même
aussi comme fait le travail de CPCR
avoir 80 90 auditions puis qu'on
travaille que sur des témoignages donc
on peut pas se baser sur un témoignage
donc c'est des aller-retours permanents
et cetera ensuite il faut que la cour
d'appel de Paris soit aussi disponible
pour pouvoir juger correctement et là
évidemment ça ça s'encombre un peu donc
oui ce serait quand même bien d'évoluer
sur ce champl Larcher vous avez une
réponse vous ah non moi j'ai posé
plusieurs fois la question à mes
interlocuteurs k dors ou àisé je ne
comprends pas le réponse ouais je ne
comprends pas leur réponse alors quelle
est la réponse qui vous fournissent bah
c'est ce que ce que vous avez dit oui
c'est ça avec l'idée de la non
rétroactivité des lois sauf que pour
Barbie par exemple on a tout à fait
appliqué la non enfin la réct enfin
Barbie non seulement on a demandé son
extradition pour un crime qui n'était
pas défini par la loi quand il a été
commis et et heureusement qu'on l'a fait
et et c'est ça qui est assez assez fou
c'est que on se permet avec le Randa des
choses qu'on supporterait pas pour
nous-mêmes imaginez un imaginez qu'on a
refusé que le pays dans lequel Barbie se
trouvait c'était réfugié et un refusé
l'extradition en France au titre pour
les raisons qu'on nous que la France
évoque c'est-à-dire bah non ce qu'il a
enfin la définition du crime date
d'après la Commission du crime donc il y
a pas de raison de et puis en plus à un
moment donné jusqu'en 80 il y avait la
peine de mort imaginez que un pays dise
bah non chez vous il y a la peine de
mort donc on va pas extrader un criminel
de guerre ou bien votre justice c'est
pas super en nous apparaît pas
exactement équitable voilà oui en fait
derrière des enjeux d'extradition d'une
manière générale c'est pas spécialement
lié au Ronda il y a des enjeux
diplomatiques toujours donc c'est
suivant comment dire si si on veut
ouvrir le le robiner ou le fermer c'est
ça été le cas entre la France et
l'Italie he aussi pendant des années sur
un certain nombre de criminels donc
voilà c'est ça l'histoire mais alors
mettez-vous à la place du Rwanda et
mettez-vous à la place des victimes du
génocide qui entendent c'est au Rwanda
de juger ces criminels c'est enfin la
France fait mais c'est faute de mieux
mais c'est d'abord à la justice randaise
de juger ces criminels qui ont commis un
crime chez eux ou êtes d'accord avec
çaoui oui non seulement je suis d'accord
mais je souscris complètement les
criminels doivent être jugés à l'endroit
même où ils ont commis des crimes je
pense c'est une question aussi de
pédagogie et être jugé devant bah devant
les les victimes devant la population
parce que tout ça aussi est pédagogique
il y a des enfants des petits enfants de
génocidaire aussi aujourd'hui ce serait
bien qu'ils entendent ses procès dans
les villages là où on enquiète hein il y
a eu des procès gachacha bien sûr mais
ça commence à être loin les les la
fermeture cétait en 2012 de mémoire donc
ce serait vraiment très bien que
Monsieur bigoua qui vient d'être jugé
ici à Paris euh il aurait été très très
bien qu'il soit jugé là-bas chez lui
àanza l'endroit où il a commis tous ses
crimes il en a commis beaucoup à
différents endroits mais au moins qu'il
soit là tout près de la gendarmerie où
il travaillait euh tout près du tribunal
qu'il soit jugé la suite maintenant vous
continuez bien sûr hein sans relâche
avec cette question qu'on est obligé de
se poser néanmoins
euh est-ce qu'il faut finir cette traque
un jour est-ce qu'il faut tourner la
page
peut-être au nom d'une réconciliation
nationale au Rwanda oou est-ce que vous
allez continuer cette traque
inlassablement et parce que c'est
l'engagement d'une vie bon j'allais le
génocide c'est un crime qui ne vieillit
pas à partir du moment c'est
imprescriptible il faut le rappeler
c'est un crime
imprescriptible donc je ne vois pas
comment on peut savoir qu'il y a un
criminel génocidaire quelque part et
rester
euh silencieux ou ne rien faire de toute
façon c'est un travail citoyen de c'est
pas que nous nous d'ailleurs on agit au
sein du CPCR donc la le collectif des
parti civil je je je remercie tous les
membres du CPCR qui nous permettent de
faire ce travail ainsi que nos avocats
parce que sans eux ce serait vraiment
difficile de toute façon de le faire euh
mais en tout état de cause nous il faut
continuer c'est pas que nous en fait il
faut tout citoyen devrait se saisir de
cette question de faire juger les
criminels en France ça se passe comme ça
je ne vois pas les criminels sont là euh
si on le sait on doit ref faaire on doit
leedénoncer 30 ans après ou presque
crime imprescriptible la traque va
continuer aussi du côté des forces de
l'ordre alors pour moi absolument aucun
des adames ouais à partir du moment où
alors et c'est d'ailleurs le principe
euh même de la compétence universelle en
France que l'on a appliqué euh c'est
quand même bien de ne pas avoir de
bourreaux qui vivent tranquillement sur
notre territoire et qui peuvent comme ça
profiter aussi des largesses de la
France c'est quand même un peu ça le le
la clé du du problème et ça concerne le
Rwanda mais aussi euh tous les pays qui
éventuellement euh enfin tous les
individus qui viennent se réfugier en
France qui viennent de Syrie RDC enfin
tout ce qu'on veut bon voilà pour moi il
y a aucun état d'âme on doit les
poursuivre sans relâche merci he
vraiment un grand merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat dog
consacré à la traque des génocidaires W
day avec ce documentaire exclusif que
nous avons proposé aujourd'hui réalisé
je le rappelle hein par Thomas RBI et
Stéphane Joubert vous pouvez bien
entendu réagir à cette émission et ça
sera sur hashtagdbadoc merci aussi à
Selma sali qui comme l'accoutumé m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un prochain débat
doc même place même heure et toujours
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt